يبدو وكان هذه قريه يملؤها الفقر والوحي
لكن في الواقع هذا مخيم دوميز للسوريين
الذين لجؤوا الى شمال العراق ويطغى عليه
شعور بالاقامه الطويله هنا تمتزج اصوات
السوق المكشوف مع الاصوات الصادره عن
ورشات البناء وبكاء الاطفال يدعون دار
خالد الى ما يسميه منزله والذي لا يعرف
الى متى ستصل هذه التسميه لصيقه له قرار
لولادي الامن من انه هلا والله مظاهره او
هيك شو نشوف التلفزيون وكل ما في شيء واما
عليهم يعني انه ال
هذه طبيعه الحادث الطبي لكن ما اثار
انتباهنا بالفعل كانت الاجواء المختلفه و
مزاج الاشخاص هنا عن ما شهدناه لدى لقائنا
عددا من اللاجئين السوريين في الاردن
وتركيا ولبنان وتتعدد الاسباب من وراء ذلك
منها لانه لا يواجهون الاهانه التي عاشها
في بلادهم اذ لا يطلبون هنا الى التسول او
البحث في القمامه ولا يتعرضون للاضطهاد
كما تتعدد اسباب رحيلهم اذ ان اكثر
المتواجدين في هذا المخيم ومن سكان
المناطق الكرديه في شمال شرق سوريا
وبعد اعوام طويله من الاهمال والفقر في ظل
نظام الاسد فان العديد من الاكراد في
السابق الى الهجره الى المدن الكبيره مع
عائلاتهم للعمل ومع انتشار العنف عادوا
الى الاقليم وجدوا الامان لكن لم يكن
هنالك مجال لايجاد لقمه العيش لكن هنا
يمكنهم من العمل
بعضهم يقيم اسواقا داخل المخيم نفسه
المستسلمين لفكره بان بقائهم هنا سيطول
لاشهر اول اعوام قبل ان يتمكن من العوده
الى منازلهم
هؤلاء الرجال عملوا على جمع خبراتهم
والمصادر المتاحه لديهم يفتحوا مخبزا اذ
ارتفعت اسعار الخبز في بلادهم الى حدود
خياليه لكن هنا يمكن تحمل تكلفته لكن
الارقام تشهد تزايدا ملحوظا اذ ان
القادمين الجدد ينتظرون في خيم مؤقته
ريثما يتم نقلهم الى مساكن مزوده للطاقه
الكهربائيه وتكون هذا المشروع من خلال
جهود مشتركه بين الامم المتحده وحكومه
اقليم كردستان التي ساهمت باعطاء اثني عشر
مليون دولار حتى الان
وتقول للمحاوله الميدانيه تفيد منظمه
اليونيسف ب اربيل بان كلا من خدمات الطرق
والكهرباء مزوده من جانب الحكومه اما
الخيام والمطابخ تقوم عليها الامم المتحده
ومنظمه اليونسيف ويعمل اللاجئون على تحسين
ظروفهم بانفسهم مقيمين بانهم س يعيشون هنا
لفتره غير محدده